as part of the NCAA west region
tournament right here in Las Vegas the
Gonzaga Bulldogs will be a T-Mobile
Arena tonight it's homecoming too for
one of their leading scorers you may
remember Julian Strother was a standout
at Liberty High School just a few years
ago yeah so our Brian will went and
talked with one of trothers teachers
there as well as the school's current
basketball coach
school spirit is on Full display here at
Liberty High School as one of their
former basketball Stars takes to the
court
Strother for three got it number zero on
the Gonzaga Bulldogs Julian Strother
still has an impact on his alma mater
Julian added to that culture of this is
somewhere that kids want to be Ashley
vanis was straher's favorite teacher and
she remembers how he would go out of his
way to talk to everyone at school we
keep in touch you know he's busy but I
love following his success I love seeing
everything that he's doing men's head
basketball coach Kevin Soares saw
strawhur from the opposite side of the
Court he was definitely a problem for us
[Applause]
driver
but now he leads strawhart's former team
at Liberty High he's got a lot bigger a
lot stronger
he's uh can shoot the ball a lot a lot
better you know from
I saw him in high school
high school games just some Bruce
improved drastically I thought you know
going against that was a very good fit
for just so grateful that we have had so
many of those moments here at Liberty
and that Julian has been a part of
bringing those moments to this it's not
only him what he does brings it to the
entire student body and that's really
cool and of course they'll all be
watching the game reporting Henderson
Ryan will